Jeremy Bella we discussed fisheries at  length and we invested lots of energy  the success is obvious I'm very pleased  to announced that the council has  arrived at a unanimous agreement  slovakia presidency have been able to  ensure unanimity the purpose of the  agreement was to ensure sustainability  of fish populations in the waters of the  EU and non-eu waters taken into account  the socio-economic impact on the  fisheries sector today we have taken  another important step towards  sustainable fisheries towards achieving  decor objective of the European Union's  Common Fisheries Policy I am proud to  say that our push for healthy fish  stocks is starting to pay off following  years of disciplined Fisheries Policy  scientists this year advised increasing  catch limits for several stocks in the  Atlantic and North Sea this is  encouraging and this shows that  sustainability really does get fishermen  the best deal